Cuál es la situación que enfrentan las
personas que en estos momentos se
encuentran dentro de Sudán
Bueno pues en este momento en Sudán como
sabemos la violencia la inseguridad está
presente en en varias zonas del país
tenemos que recordar que Sudán es un
país en el cual un tercio de la
población ya tenía necesidades
humanitarias antes de la escalada de
violencia que estamos viendo estos días
y que acogía a más de un millón de
refugiados estas personas necesitan
ayuda que en este momento no está
llegando nuestros equipos siguen dentro
del país pero obviamente en algunas
zonas donde la seguridad no lo permite
no podemos tener el mismo acceso a las
familias más vulnerables que el que
teníamos hace tan solo dos semanas en
otras partes del país seguimos
ofreciendo esa ayuda y sobre todo pues
vemos que hay movimiento dentro del país
personas que salen de distintos sitios
de darfur de harton de la capital hacia
otras zonas en las que hay más seguridad
y después pues como comentabas Valentina
otras personas que no tienen otra opción
más que cruzar una frontera y buscar esa
seguridad
en países vecinos a Sudán bueno y
justamente le pregunto por ellos Cuáles
son las principales carencias que
encuentran los ciudadanos que han tenido
que huir a otras naciones
la mayoría de los de los refugiados que
están huyendo otras naciones están
llegando a Egipto chat Sudán del sur o
sea Sudán del sur muchos de ellos son
refugiados que estaban en Sudán Y que
ahora tienen que volver no les queda
otra opción más que volver a su país a
veces a comunidades inestables muchos de
ellos llegan con necesidades de apoyo
psicosocial tras vivir pues momentos de
violencia y traumáticos bastante
importantes hay mujeres embarazadas a
las que se les está apoyando en este
momento también personas con necesidades
médicas y sobre todo pues hay muchos de
ellos que están quedándose en zonas y en
aldeas muy cercanas a la frontera en la
que no hay muchos servicios son
servicios que que corren el riesgo de
saturarse otras familias están viviendo
Por ejemplo bajo árboles o en tiendas
que están haciendo ellos mismos con lo
poco que tienen y son también familias
que llevan con muy pocos recursos
económicos que han dejado todo atrás Así
que esa ayuda humanitaria de emergencia
en fronteras está siendo
está siendo vital en este momento y
crucial Y bueno pues estamos
preparándonos también tanto acnur como
nuestros socios de otras organizaciones
humanitarias y los gobiernos de los
países vecinos para para estar equipados
y hacer frente a la llegada de de otros
refugiados en los próximos días si la
situación continúa igual que en estas
últimas semanas bueno Y es que
justamente usted lo estaba mencionando
este desplazamiento masivo está
afectando a países vecinos que también
viven sus propios conflictos en estos
momentos Cuál es la prioridad
la prioridad en este momento es
asegurarnos de que tenemos suficientes
equipos en frontera para ayudar a estas
personas que están llegando y la
logística en marcha para poder moverlas
y desplazarlas y relocalizarlas a otras
zonas que a otras zonas más lejanas a la
frontera en las cuales sí que hay
servicios que que puedan atender a sus
necesidades Pero obviamente la principal
prioridad es que esta situación se
resuelva que haya que vuelva la paz y
que las personas puedan retornar a sus
comunidades Y por último también es
urgente esa ayuda de la comunidad
internacional esa ayuda financiera para
que los países vecinos que han mostrado
una gran apertura han mantenido y siguen
manteniendo las fronteras abiertas para
acoger a todos los que han tenido que
huir tras esta escalada de violencia
para que puedan hacer frente a esas
necesidades a esa ayuda humanitaria que
va a necesitarse en los próximos días
bueno y justamente con el panorama
actual ustedes ven factible el final de
los enfrentamientos a corto plazo que se
necesitaría y hasta dónde podría llegar
la crisis y los choques continúan
bueno como como todos los humanitarios
lo que lo que esperamos es que las
hostilidades cesen cuanto antes vemos
estos altos al fuegos anunciados es
importante que se mantengan porque lo
primordial en este momento es poder
continuar dando la ayuda humanitaria a
esas personas que que lo necesitaban y
que muchas de ellas dependían de ellas
dentro de Sudán y que esas personas que
han tenido que huir pues puedan retornar
a su vida normal lo antes posible